هو قديم يعني هم استخدموا لما توفي رشيد
رضا صاحب مجله المنار اعاده اصدار جديد
بنفس التوجهات واستاجروا بعض الصحف
والمجلات وفي مراحل هم تحالف ومع الكسر
الملك فاروق وتحالف مع ويهاجمون غده سرا
وتحالفه مع الضباط الذين قاموا بالانقلاب
وهم يسمى الثوره عام 52 ثم انقلبوا عليهم
في همم الواقع الشهيره وانقلب عليهم ايضا
جمال عبد الناصر تحالفهم على الوفد تقريبا
ثلاث مرات عام 51 من الانتخابات الشهريه
الشهيره ضد الخصوم السعوديين وغيرهم ثم في
عام 84 ثم ايضا في مراحل لاحقا في 2011
والوفد حزب الوفده وحزب البرالي علماني
تختلف همم مناهجه ومبادئه تمام
وحزب الاشتراك في مرحله معينه
واستطاعه بالقوه العدديه في مرحله ما
يسموه حزب الاشتراك وبعدين صار الحزب
العمل الاسلامي
كانت جريده الشعب الصادره باسمه وتحالفوا
مع كل التيارات وتحالف حتى في خارج في
خارج القطر المصري في الاقطار الاخرى